[Musica]
sono io
buongiorno a tutti nei prossimi minuti
proverò a fare una cosa che devo
confessarvi che non è tanto nelle mie
corde
come avrete sicuramente già intuito non
è nelle mie corde nemmeno stare su un
palco però sono qui
e a proposito di connessioni proverò a
cercare insieme a voi il filo rosso che
connette due parole secondo me molto
importanti la prima è vocazione e la
seconda è responsabilità
partiamo da vocazione guidos voi lo
sapete qual è la vostra vocazione
fra i tanti fili rossi
qual è il nostro la cosa per cui siamo
nati
la cosa giusta per noi non è mai facile
capire qual è la nostra strada
qual è il nostro destino almeno per me
non è stato facile
normalmente si pensa che uno sia
destinato a fare quello che bravo a fare
ma da piccola sembrava che io fossi
brava a fare tutto vi sembrerà
paradossale ma quando è così le cose si
complicano
ricordo benissimo quando è stato il
momento il punto in cui ho fatto clic è
stato quando a un certo punto ho smesso
di fare le cose per fare piacere agli
altri di fare le cose perfette le cose
belle anche se tutti sembravano contenti
io non lo ero
perché capivo che non mi bastava
e allora cosa ho fatto ho iniziato a
scrivere numeri e lettere ovunque e
allegare le cose fra di loro e lo facevo
di nascosto
non sapevo esattamente perché capivo che
era una cosa che mi apparteneva non
sapevo nemmeno se ero brava ma non mi
interessava non era non era questo il
punto
e in effetti detto così sembra una cosa
da pazzi o da artisti devo dire che è
stato in quel momento che ha iniziato il
mio che è iniziato il mio percorso di
artista
allora non lo sapevo ma adesso lo so
oggi questo percorso è sotto gli occhi
di tutti non è più nascosto e la gente
mi chiede e si chiede ma perché scrivi
calendari per che leghi le cose fra di
loro
cosa vogliono a dire gli alberi legati
perché faccio le cose che faccio e vi
confesso che il mio gallerista se lo
domanda ancora lui ha scritto una cosa
che suona come a letizia ci lega un
sottile filo rosso e l'ho letta talmente
tante volte che me lo ricordo a memoria
lui dice col fino a lei nun te se non
disfa semmai ricama dedicati disegni in
punta dago e io mi sto chiedendo cosa
cosa fa
cosa ci vuole dire cosa mi vuole dire
con quel filo di un rosso incandescente
con le sedie legate con le tazzine con
gli alberi con le mosche sotto i
bicchieri lasciamo per un secondo in
disparte queste domande e torniamo al
momento in cui ho fatto clic
allora non lo sapevo però adesso lo so
avevo imparato a percepire meglio me
stessa e la connessione profonda fra il
mio mondo interno e il mondo intorno a
me provo a spiegarmi un po meglio per
farlo devo scomodare la santa caterina
niente popò di meno perché caterina è
stata una di quelle donne che hanno
costruito un proprio progetto per
opporsi a un programma stabilito da
altri
suo padre voleva chiuderla in una stanza
e lei ha estremizzato il gesto di suo
padre
e in questo modo è diventata la padrona
della situazione praticamente come dire
tu credi di chiudermi dentro sono invece
io a chiuderti fuori e così caterina si
è costruita quella che lei ha chiamato
con un'espressione meravigliosa la
camera della mente
tutti abbiamo una camera della mente non
solo caterina non solo gli artisti
peccato che non sempre ci andiamo
è un luogo interiore è un posto dove lo
spazio del tempo sono diversi da lì le
cose si vedono diversamente è tutto più
chiaro
lì non arrivano le voci da fuori
l'unica voce che si sente la propria
voce interna che è una voce sincera
gentile è un come un rifugio è una casa
e i progetti nascono lì le connessioni
fra dentro e fuori vanno e vengono da lì
stabilire delle connessioni è una cosa
possibile se dentro e fuori comunicano
se stiamo solamente fuori sempre fuori
ci può capitare di vivere secondo un
programma e non secondo un progetto e io
ho imparato a entrare e uscire
virtualmente da questa stanza ea
trasformare le intuizioni i pensieri i
pensieri in immagini
e le immagini nazioni questo è un po la
linea che che è venuta fuori da sé ma
perché c'era già come tutti l'abbiamo
già le intuizioni nascono dentro e poi
si trasformano in azioni che vanno fuori
e queste azioni sono diverse da quelle
che compiamo abitualmente il più delle
volte o quelle che facciamo perché
qualcun altro ci dice che cosa dobbiamo
fare
costruiscono delle connessioni che ci
appartengono che ci somigliano e quindi
hanno senso e per farvi capire un po
meglio ancora perché per gli artisti non
è automatico parlare se io fossi brava a
parlare non farei quello che faccio
parlerei invece ci provo in qualche modo
poi metto le immagini e spero che questo
connetta ma per farvi capire un po
meglio di cosa sto parlando
mi viene appunto in mente un esercizio
che si faceva nelle scuole di pittura ne
era un esercizio di visione molto molto
bello quando ci si trova a un punto
morto di un quadro senza capire che cosa
non funziona senza sapere come andare
avanti e dove intervenire
si volta al quadro lo si mette a testa
in giù e lo si guarda da lontano lo si
guarda praticamente dal buco della
serratura della camera della mente ed è
un rimedio infallibile straordinario
immediatamente risulta perfettamente
visibile qual è il punto su cui bisogna
intervenire
anche nella vita si può fare così se
siamo incastrati in una situazione in
cui ci sentiamo in trappola in cui
niente gira come dovrebbe
ci si tira fuori dalla situazione è la
si guarda da lontano
nel quadro è questione di pesi e di
relazioni
guardando sempre da vicino e dallo
stesso punto i giusti pesi e le giuste
relazioni non si vedono sono invisibili
si vedono sempre e solo le stesse cose
dallo stesso punto
allontanandosi e guardando diversamente
invece si vedono i pesi delle cose come
in un cosmo il giorno in cui ho fatto
clic è stato il giorno in cui ho
imparato ho imparato che esiste uno
schema segreto che collega le cose le
persone e tutto quello che ci circonda
che dai visibile può essere reso
visibile entrando nella camera della
mente si senta ed invisibile se uno sa
sentire e vedere l'invisibile si svela
il linguaggio del quadro o della vita
powerplay che era veramente una gran
persona
diceva il quadro è finito quando il
quadro ti guarda cioè è lui che ti dice
qualcosa di te del mondo mentre tu
pensavi di essere tu e avere qualcosa da
dire ma la cosa importante è che questo
gesto non è una prerogativa degli
artisti è una cosa che ci riguarda tutti
come esseri umani la cosa importante è
la cosa che conta è percepire questo
schema invisibile in cui noi siamo
immersi per capire qual è la nostra
direzione la cosa fondamentale è vedere
dove stiamo a noi in questa ragnatela
misteriosa che è molto più grande
di quello che ci sembrava mentre ci
sentivamo intrappolati e capirlo
significa rispondere alle domande da cui
eravamo partiti io oggi leggo gli alberi
le tazzine scrivo i calendari cui cio
per rimediare ai danni per rimettere
insieme le cose legate per ricostruire
delle connessioni per unire il visibile
all'invisibile in modo che si
ricostituiscano delle unità e che tutto
faccia parte di un grande del grande
quadro e la domanda è cosa succedono
delle cose quando sono legate stando in
piedi meglio possono essere un po
impedite nei loro movimenti però
rivelano degli aspetti della loro forma
e delle possibilità di interpretazione
che prima non si vedevano così
evidenziano uno spazio che esisteva già
ma che non si vedeva in questo modo
quello fra gli alberi per esempio quando
uno capisce che lo spazio può essere
diverso capisce nel senso di sentire
sente e vede che lo spazio può essere
diverso cambia anche la sua relazione
con l'altra dimensione fondante della
nostra vita che è il tempo e quando ci
prendiamo cura del tempo quasi sempre ci
stiamo prendendo cura di noi stessi
delle cose e del mondo e siamo e ci
sentiamo sulla nostra strada e siamo e
ci sentiamo connessi a qualche cosa che
è molto più grande e quindi non ci
sentiamo soli
ecco perché io scrivo i calendari
leggo le tazzine le sedi
e curcio per rimediare ai danni oggi non
mi faccio più tante domande perché so
che la cosa importante per me è sentire
e vedere con gli occhi della mente
oggi so che il filo conduttore del mio
lavoro è la spiritualità connessione per
me vuol dire percepire questa dimensione
dell'invisibile sempre ormai la cerco in
ogni istante della mia vita
la sento la riconosco guardo le forme e
capisco se chiedono di essere legate e
come e qual e la loro dimensione di
tempo ma in realtà tutti possono cercare
la connessione possono sentirla e
vederla magari perderla e poi ritrovarla
e quando l'abbiamo ritrovata e riusciamo
a mantenerla
capiamo che siamo noi stessi che siamo
abbiamo trovato la camera della mente è
come un profumo che si spande su tutte
le cose potremmo mettere la parola
talento al posto di profumo come
riconoscerlo ciascuno al suo ha un buon
profumo sa di buono
praticamente no ed è la cosa che per noi
conta quindi credo che la cosa
importante per tutti noi sia attivare
questa conoscenza che esiste fra le
mille domande che mi sono state fatte e
che in qualche modo hanno centrato la
mia ricerca mi hanno aiutata a crescere
ce n'è una che considero centrale e che
è stata proprio come una freccia in
mezzo al bersaglio e che mi aiuta a
portarvi alla seconda questione che è
quella della responsabilità
ed alla domanda che mi ha fatto uno dei
miei figli rocco che davanti a un
calendario non mi ha chiesto di
spiegarglielo che cosa volesse dire lui
mi ha chiesto mamma perché hai voluto
farlo
ed ecco che si svela cosa c'è dall'altra
parte del capo del filo rosso
da una parte c'è la chiamata che è la
vocazione
dall'altra parte c'è la risposta la
responsabilità la responsabilità di
seguirla la vocazione quando abbiamo
capito chi siamo
qual è il nostro talento cosa ne
facciamo di chi siamo
e questa è una domanda con cui vi lascio
perché la domanda
e ancora sempre oggi in ogni momento
anche alla mia domanda
grazie
[Applauso]